foreign
I'm going to try to start promptly at
1105 each time so welcome is everybody
psyched
I'm psyched
uh this is 9 13 the human brain I'm
Nancy camwisher I'm the Prof for this
class
unless you were wondering I have a brain
and there it is that's me
with some bits colored in that you will
learn about in this class okay
what I'm going to do today is I'm going
to tell you a brief story for around 10
minutes
and then I'm going to talk about the why
how and what of studying the human brain
why it's a cool thing to do how you do
it and what in particular we're going to
learn about in here and then we'll do
some mechanics and details of the course
and allocation of grades and all that
it's on the syllabus anyway
cool
that's the agenda
all right so let's start with that story
for this I'm gonna sit up here
um the story isn't that long but it has
a lot of interesting little weird bits
so I have cue cards to remind myself of
all the bits I want to remember to say
um so you can put away your phones and
your computers and you don't need to
take notes this is just a story
it's going to foreshadow a lot of the
themes in the course but it's not stuff
you're going to be tested on okay
so
um this is a true story
and I've changed only a few tiny little
bits to protect the identity of the
people involved but otherwise it's an
absolutely true story
it's a story about a scary medical
situation that happened to a friend of
mine a few years ago
but at the same time it's a story about
the nature of the human mind
about the organization of the human
brain
and it's also a story about the ability
or lack thereof to recover after brain
damage
it's also incidentally a story about
resilience
privilege expertise and all of those
things that are characteristic of many
people in Cambridge Society
um not so relevant for the course but
all right here goes
um so a few years ago a friend of mine
was staying over at my house in
Cambridge on route to a conference in a
nearby state
and this guy I'll call him Bob was a
close friend of mine I'd known him for
years and years
we had we talked regularly we went on
hiking trips together we were pretty
close
so he's on route to this conference he's
staying over at my house the night
before
um and he the plan was for him to get up
early the next morning and drive to the
conference so we hung out the night
before and chatted and the next morning
he's sleeping in the Next Room over from
mine and early in the morning I hear
some shuffling I think yep okay Bob is
packing to leave and thank God I don't
need to get up I'm only dimly awake and
so I'm not paying that much attention
Shuffle Shuffle in the background
and then I hear a crash
and I think what the hell is that
and I get up and I go into the Next Room
and Bob is lying on the floor
not moving
I say Bob
and there's no answer
and then I showed Bob
and there's no answer
and then I dialed 9-1-1
while we were sitting there waiting for
the ambulance to arrive Bob starts to
wake up
and he's very woozy but he's alive and
he's making a little bit of sense
and he can't figure out what's going on
and neither can I
and so we're talking and chatting and
he's making a little more sense
but we still don't know what's happening
so then the ambulance arrives incredibly
fast so like three minutes boom there's
three EMTs rushing in the front door
rushing up to the room where Bob was and
they take all his vitals
and they can't find anything wrong
and so they're really casual I guess
they confront stuff like this all the
time I don't Bob doesn't but they're
very calm about it and they're saying
well
can take him to the hospital or not
and I was like I think we need to know
what just happened even though he seems
okay we kind of need to know what this
is all about don't you think they're
like yeah you come to the ER
and I said well do we need to waste
ambulance resources or do you think it's
safe if I drive him myself since there's
a hospital not far away I said you can
drive him yourself
so I drive Bob to the Mount Auburn
Hospital ER which is like less than a
mile from my house
and we do the usual ER thing which is
mostly waiting and waiting and waiting
but various docs come by and they take
all these tests and they take all these
history questions and it goes on and on
and basically they're just not finding
anything
so after about an hour or two of this
they're still doing tests they don't
want to quite let them go yet because
they don't know what happened
everybody's calm about it I figure okay
fine I got work to do
and I tell Bob
um you know text me throughout the day
and I'll come get you whenever they're
ready to release you
and so
um
I go into work
but just before I go into work
the thought flashes through my mind
and I say to the ER doc you know
you should check Bob's brain
and the reason that thought flashed
through my mind is that actually I had
been worrying about Bob
for a number of years and I hadn't
really it hadn't quite registered
consciously I hadn't was kind of too
horrifying a thought for me to really
allow myself to realize I was worried
about Bob's brain but I was worried
about a very particular thing and that
is that Bob had been showing these weird
signs that he often got lost
and didn't know where he was
and on the one hand this just didn't
make any sense because he was fine in
every other way
but it was really pretty striking so one
time
I was over at Bob's house with some
other friends of ours and the friend
asked Bob how do we get how do I drive
from your house into Cambridge
and Bob said well you go to the end of
the driveway and you turn left
my friend and I looked at each other
like
Bob what and Bob thinks about it for a
minute yeah into the driveway turn left
I just had this like sinking feeling of
dread in the pit of my stomach
but we sort of made light of it and made
fun of it and it went by it was like no
you turn right and we gave the
directions
another time A friend of mine was
driving with Bob in Bob's hometown
and noticed that like Bob didn't seem to
know how to get to the grocery store
in his hometown where he lived for a
really long time and you know a trip
he'd made hundreds of times
another time I was at a conference in
Germany
and I saw you know these arrays of
posters of people presenting usually
pretty dry scientific things and out of
the corner of my eye I see the title of
a poster and it says navigational
deficits colon and early sign of
Alzheimer's and I saw that and I just
thought
and I just kind of suppressed the
thought
oh my God Bob wasn't that old I know
Alzheimer's can very rarely strike early
I just I didn't want to think about it
but it was like rattling around in the
back of back of my consciousness
so there had been these signs
but as I say they didn't make sense
because Bob was holding down a very high
powered job he was writing beautiful
prose he was the life of every party he
was at witty funny everybody's like
favorite life of the party
so how could that be like it just didn't
make sense that there would be anything
wrong with Bob's brain
so I managed for a few years to notice
these signs and ignore them and not pay
any attention
um
so
the killer thing is
I should have known better
my research for the last 20 years has
been on the very fact that there are
different parts of the brain that do
different things
and one of the coral areas of that
is you can have a problem with one of
those parts and the other parts can work
just fine
and so I if anyone should have realized
yes there's something really wrong with
Bob's navigation abilities and the fact
that he's smart and witty and funny and
holding down a high-powered job doesn't
mean there isn't something wrong with
his brain with a part of his brain
but I didn't realize that
but then you know as I'm leaving the ER
it kind of all clicked and I said to the
ER doc you better check his brain
I thought Bob was out of earshot when I
said that he heard it he's like what I
was like oh never mind
um anyway the ER doc with the kind of
confidence that only docs can muster or
said nope not a brain thing this is a
hard thing
which wasn't exactly reassuring
um but I set aside the brain thought
um and I went off to work
so
throughout the day I texted with Bob a
few times
things seemed to be fine they'd done
more tests they weren't finding anything
we just got calmer and calmer about it I
guess sometimes weird stuff happens and
you just move on
but then that night around seven or
eight at night I was over at a friend's
house and the phone rang
and it was Bob I picked it up and Bob
says
get over here
they found something in my brain
so I ran out of the house grabbed my
phone and as I'm driving to the Mount
Auburn ER
I called my trusty lab tech an amazing
guy who keeps track of all kinds of
things much better than I do and I said
I remember that we scanned Bob a bunch
of years ago for a regular experiment in
my lab
and I don't remember the date I don't
remember anything about it but dig
around in the files and see if you can
figure it out it might be useful to have
that scan
so by the time I get to the ER my lab
tech is already texted me back and said
found the scans I'm putting them in a
Dropbox for you
so I go into the ER and there's Bob in
the ER Doc and Bob says to me
um
do you want to see it the ER dock or the
radiologist has already shown Bob the
picture of his brain
and so they take me in there
and I look at it and I gulped there was
a thing the size of a lime smack in the
middle of his brain
pretty terrifying
so
um
this lime in the middle of Bob's brain
was right next to a region that my lab
had studied in great detail in fact my
lab had discovered that a brain region
right next to where that lime was
located was specifically involved in
navigation
how could I not have put all this
together but I didn't until that moment
and I thought of course of course
there's a thing in his brain right next
to the para hippocampal Place area which
I discovered and a nearby related region
called retrospolineal cortex of course
and how the hell could I not have known
but I didn't know
um in that earlier work
it had been nearly 20 years ago I had a
postdoc named Russell Epstein and
Russell was a computer vision guy and he
wanted to understand how we see by
writing code
to duplicate the algorithms that he
thought go on in the human brain when we
understand visual images
and that's a very respectable cool line
of work which we'll learn a little bit
about in here
and Russell was really a coding guy at
the time we were just starting doing
brain Imaging
but Russell was like poo pooing at all
it's like the flash in the pan it's
going to go by it's trashy so you guys
get nice blobs on the brain I'm not
having any of it and I kept saying
Russell you need to get a job just do
one experiment so you can show in your
job talk that you can do brain Imaging
it might help you you don't need to do a
lot of it just do one dumb experiment
Russell was interested in how we
recognize scenes not just objects and
faces and words but how do we know where
we are and how do we recognize if the
scene as a city or a beach or whatever
it is
I said okay Russell we'll just scan
people looking at pictures of scenes and
looking at other kinds of pictures and
we'll just kind of see if there's any
part of the brain that responds a lot to
scenes it really was not well thought
out this is not how you should do an
experiment it shouldn't be based on
political calculations lack of theory
any of the above but the fact is that's
why we did that experiment Russell
needed to be able to show a brain image
in his job talk so we scan some people
looking at scenes
and the results knocked our socks off we
found a part of the brain that responds
very selectively when you look at images
of scenes not when you look at faces
objects words or pretty much anything
else
and so we'll learn more about that later
in the course we called it the para
hippocampal Place area and that launched
a whole major line of work in my lab and
now dozens of other labs around the
world
so backtrack we'd already found that
region and here's this lime in my friend
Bob's brain sitting right next to the
para hit the gamble Place area
okay
so then
I remembered let's look at the scans
from my lab from a few years ago in
Bob's brain
and so I fiddled around and found
managed to download the files
and there it was you could see that same
blob but in the scans from a few years
before it was much smaller it was the
size of a grape
right
and so that told us a bunch of things
most importantly it told us this thing
is growing really slowly
and that was hugely important because
brain tumors are very bad news and they
usually grow really fast and the fact
that it grew really slowly told us that
this was not one of the kind of worst
most invasive most horrible ones it was
clearly a problem it was big but at
least it wasn't growing hugely fast
but how poignant that there it was in my
own damn data and I hadn't seen it in my
friend's brain
well I'm not a radiologist
I'm a basic researcher and I didn't look
and I didn't see it
um so indeed the next day the uh the
docs told us that they thought this was
meningioma not cancer who knew that you
could have tumors that weren't cancer
but you can and they still need to come
out if they're big enough and that's
very serious but it's not as bad as
having a cancer in your brain
um so as we're collecting information
the next day I'm hanging out in the
hospital room and there was an amusing
moment when one of the residents came by
and he's taking the history and asking
all the basic questions and I said kind
of sheepishly because you don't want to
seem like you know more than the
residents and in fact I didn't really
know more but I just thought I'd provide
a little information I said you know
he's actually had symptoms for a bunch
of years and there's a there's a region
of the brain nearby that you know that
I've actually studied a little bit and
the residence is like we know who you
are
[Laughter]
um so much for my you know trying to
stay under the radar
um
I that afternoon I talked to a
neurosurgeon friend of mine because I
figured okay we need we need advice we
need help and the um the neurosurgeon
friend said
um
quote it like got branded in my brain
she said it is a Paramount importance
that you find the best neurosurgeon it's
the difference between whether Bob dies
on the table or goes on to live a normal
life
so this is the privileged part of the
story I'm not that well connected but
I'm a little bit connected and I kind of
dug around and did what I could and
we spent a couple of weeks and we found
the best neurosurgeon
and
the night before the surgery
Bob is staying over at my house because
the surgery was in a Boston hospital and
I thought you know I've been dancing
around this for years but now like it's
all out in the open we know there's a
problem and I'm going to test him I'm
going to find out what the hell's going
on
this is after all one of the basic forms
of data that we collect in my field that
is testing people with problems in their
brain to try to figure out what things
they can do and what things they can't
do it's a way of figuring out what the
basic components of the mind and brain
are it's actually the oldest most
venerable method in our field and it's
still a hugely important one
so I thought what the hell so I said
okay Bob draw me a sketch map of the
floor plan of your house
and so Bob takes a few minutes and he
draws this thing
and it was shy
there weren't even you know the the
rooms in a kind of rectilinearly
arranged house they weren't even aligned
there was like a soup of wine so there
was no organization from one room to the
next
and Bob kind of realized this kind of
isn't right is it but he didn't know how
to fix it and he said he just couldn't
visualize what it looked like to be in
his house and so we couldn't draw the
floor plan
and I thought okay he hasn't been there
in a couple of days I gave him another
piece of paper and I said okay draw the
floor plan of my house where you are
right now
um and so Bob took a couple minutes and
delivered a similar mess
he couldn't even imagine the layout of
the room next to him that he'd been at
been in a few minutes before
and then trying to channel my inner
neuropsychologist I thought okay
gave him another piece of paper and I
said okay Bob try a draw a bicycle why
did I choose a bicycle because it's a
multi-part object that has a bunch of
different bits that have a particular
relationship to each other just as the
rooms in a house have a particular
spatial relationship to each other and I
wanted to know is his problem
specifically about places or is it out
about any complex multi-part thing that
you have to remember the relationships
to
Bob is no artist to put it mildly but
his bicycle was clearly recognizable as
a bicycle it had the two wheels in the
right relationship and you know it had
all the basic parts in roughly the same
the right place
I then had him draw a lobster another
multi-part object and also his Lobster
was not beautiful but had everything in
the right place
and so that's very telling he had a
specific problem in I don't know
imagining reproducing remembering it's
not totally clear
the arrangements of parts in a room but
not the arrangements of parts and an
object
okay and we'll get back to that more in
a few weeks
um okay so
um
what do I want to say here
I said all that
so the next day Bob has an 11 hour
surgery major hardcore extreme
neurosurgery remove a huge piece of bone
from the back of your head pull apart
the hemispheres of the brain like this
go in like multiple inches and remove a
lime like holy crap right
said lime was right near the vein of
Galen right Galen lived what a couple
thousand years ago the fact that there's
a vein of Galen means it's a big ass
vein the kind of vein that even Galen
would have found with you know
dissection 2000 years ago
this lime was all wrapped around and
interleaved with the vein of Galen not
good but because we found the best
neurosurgeon and because we have extreme
privilege
and all the all the possible medical
resources and expertise you could
possibly hope for
Bob sailed through the surgery and an
hour after the surgery I'm chatting with
him and he's making sense amazing
right
so
um and you know two literally two days
later they sent him home
and a few days after that he's back at
work no problem
totally fine
but now we get to the question you're
probably thinking about
what about his navigational abilities
the sad answer is
nothing doing
none of it came back at all
thank God for iPhones
if Bob lived 30 years ago he wouldn't be
able to function but he goes everywhere
using his iPhone GPS everywhere
um and this fact that he didn't recover
his navigational abilities
is consistent with the whole literature
that we'll consider later in the course
that often not always but often if you
have brain damage especially to some of
these very specialized circuits that
we'll talk about
you don't recover later
if the damage is early you may well
recover early in life you may well
recover children have much more plastic
brains that can adjust after brain
damage adults not so good
um so
Bob's doing fine
that's my story
any thoughts or questions
yeah
yes
and it's very interesting there are many
of his spatial abilities that are
absolutely intact
and yet the ones related to navigation
are not
yeah
yeah no problem but he's always looking
at his damn phone to get directions or
to listen to you know the the GPS
directions system
so driving is no problem it's another
kind of left right the immediate spatial
orientation abilities are absolutely
fine but knowing where am I now and how
would I get there from here is blitzed
other questions yeah
great question
yes he can recognize familiar places
what he can't do is he can say oh right
that's the front of our house or that's
a cafe you know that's such and such
Cafe that's near our house what he can't
do is say which way would you turn from
there to go home
like multiple scenes great question
great question a little bit
so he can navigate a little bit with his
GPS and because he's learned certain
routes as a series of almost verbal
commands like if you're here turn right
then like that whole kind of thing it's
not what any of you guys could do if you
guys are driving around in Cambridge or
walking around campus remember when they
blocked off this whole middle of Campus
a couple years ago it was so irritating
I would like go there it's like oh God
they've blocked it off I can't get over
to you know Lobby seven well you
immediately come up with an alternate
route it's like okay I guess we're going
to have to do this you come up with an
alternate route this is what you're
never a normal navigation system can do
Bob can't do that at all he's like root
block no idea get out the phone
right
yeah so you get it like estimating
distances like does he know like
something is like a certain number of
miles away yes
yes he is and that's very interesting
but that seems to be kind of a different
thing you could think about all the
different kinds of cues you have for
distance beyond your ab your kind of
literal navigation skills
uh a little bit a couple minutes yes
the next day you know I mean it would it
would be kind of like this thing it's
like you know I sort of vaguely remember
that I was here I turned right so I
better do that again
no not very well and this is a problem
because iPhones don't usually yeah so
new hotels big problem
finding the bathroom down the hall or
the front door in a hotel big problem
yeah
I mean you know these are problems you
can you can come up with workarounds but
it's not life-threatening but it's
extremely inconvenient
yeah
so this is the case
navigational skills that developed like
longer a long time ago those are
stronger so like he has a harder time
developing like it's very time you say
new hotels are a problem but different
suffix is like more familiar like his
home it's it's easier it's a great
question and you might think that the
the kind of navigational Maps you laid
down long ago would be intact so is it
just that you can't learn new ones
um so it's a it's a great question the
answer is kind of complicated in this
case for roots that he's memorized
there's a whole different system for
knowing a route and really having an
abstract knowledge of a place that
enables you to devise a new route if
something is blocked on that route right
so for highly overlearned Roots he's
okay like he remembers like the zidu
it's like a sequence it's like a it's
like a memorized motor sequence you do a
and then B and then C and then D so he's
okay with those with roots he learned
long ago
but he is not good at coming up with a
new root in a place that he learned long
ago
all right we'll take one last question
is
um and then we have conscious knowledge
that this is
no he knows well he knows because like
when he tries to figure out which way to
head he has no idea so he's extremely
aware of it and very articulate on
precisely what happens and so what he
says is like if he's looking at if he's
looking at a place here's something he
says he's looking at a place he knows
where he is because there's all kinds of
other bits of information that tell you
where you are because you intended to go
there and the relevant things are
happening and all this who knows where
he is and it looks familiar
if he tries to imagine what's behind him
he says that he like starts to get it
and it just kind of vaporizes he just
can't hang on to it he can't kind of
construct a stable mental image of
nearby places
so I don't know exactly what that means
but he's very articulate and can report
what happens what he experiences when he
tries to access this kind of information
so what you guys will go on but what I
want to say is what you guys just did
is exactly what we do in my field we try
to take a mental ability and tease it
apart and say is it exactly this or is
it exactly that and you guys all just
did it beautifully right so a lot of
what we do in my field is kind of this
kind of Common Sense parsing of mental
abilities what is a particular mental
ability you know how does it relate to
some other one are these things
separable can you lose one and not the
other do they live in different parts of
the brain Etc
all right so that's the story I'm going
to cash out some of the um uh
particular themes that that came out
from the story that will echo through
this course and the first and most
obvious one is the brain isn't just a
big bunch of mush right it has structure
it has organization the different bits
do different things okay
importantly when Bob had this big lime
in his head he didn't just get a little
bit stupid
no his IQ if he'd take an IQ test would
be unchanged he lost a very specific
mental ability okay
and that is fascinating
um but it's also good news for science
because often when you try to understand
a complicated thing a great way to make
progress is to First figure out what the
parts are and then later try to figure
out how does each individual part work
and how do they work together but if
there's part structure there's at least
a place to start
okay
second theme is that some parts of the
brain do extremely specific things right
not all of them some of them are quite
General and are engaged in lots of
different mental processes but some are
remarkably specific we'll talk a lot
about that
third big theme
the organization of the brain Echoes the
architecture of the Mind
um
and I would say the fundamental pieces
of the brain are telling us what are
fundamental parts of the mind and that's
why I'm in this field that's what I
think is cool you know the brain is just
like a bunch of cells like it's a
physical thing who cares about a
physical thing the reason we care about
it is that's where our mind lives and if
we study that physical thing we can
learn something about our minds
and that's pretty Cosmic I think
so the point of all of this kind of work
is not to say oh that mental process is
here not there who cares I don't really
care I mean at some point you need to
have a ballpark sense you need to know
to study the things but the interesting
question is not where these things are
in the brain but which mental processes
have their own specialized machinery and
why those
yeah
another important theme how do brains
change right Bob didn't recover after
his brain damage in that very particular
mental function that he lost
if it if all of that had happened when
he was five five years old he probably
would have right so how do brains change
over normal development how do they
change from learning and experience
how do they change after injury
and the final theme echoed uh in that
story is there are lots and lots of
different ways to study the brain right
they're the simple behavioral
observations Bob can't navigate but he
can do everything else okay that's
really deep and informative low-tech but
really powerful right
um the anatomical brain images that
showed where the line was in Bob's brain
right that gives you another kind of
information what's the physical
structure of the brain
the functional images that we had done
in my lab to discover the para
hippocampal Place area
and the studies of what mental abilities
are preserved and which are lost in
people who have alterations of their
brain
okay so those are just a few of the
kinds of methods in our field Each of
which tells us about a different kind of
thing about the brain okay so those are
the themes I was trying to get at here
so let's move on to um
the why how and what of exploring the
brain I'm going to sign the Tas to get
me to shut up at
um let's see we're supposed to end it
five minutes before the end of class is
that right is that MIT tradition okay so
at uh oh my shockingly soon
um 11 45
um you're gonna
um no
oh great thank you thank you this is one
of the many things Tas are for they pick
up the hundreds of typos and mindos and
all of that excellent I'm thinking how
the hell did I so miss time this thank
you heather okay good we'll go on okay
why should we study the brain
first most obvious reason know thyself
know what this thing is that's operating
in our heads this is who you are right
is your brain
there are lots of very fine and
important organs in the body
um but the brain is special
right so you know a heart is important
you die without it
but it's the brain that's your identity
right so there's a reason that surgeons
do heart transplants that makes sense
something wrong with your heart you need
another heart okay
but why don't they do brain transplants
that would make sense right if there's
something wrong with my brain it doesn't
make sense to take someone else's brain
and put it in here because then I'd be
that other person it doesn't make sense
because the brain is who you are
okay so the brain is really special it's
not just another organ
that's why a few years ago we had the
decade of the brain
right not the decade of the pancreas or
the liver or the kidney right people
need to study these things they know how
to fix the they need to know how to fix
them they're important but they're not
as Cosmic as the brain
okay
all right
um
second reason why we should understand
brains
and that is to understand the limits of
human knowledge
like the more we understand about the
human mind the more we can like actually
evaluate how good our knowledge is
are there things that we might not be
able to think
possible true scientific theories we
might not be able to understand ever
you can think of studying the Mind as a
kind of empirical epistemology a way to
actually know about the knower so we can
figure out how good the knowledge is in
that knower
right so that's another
reason
a third reason is to advance AI
and so up until a few years ago I used
to give lectures on vision and they
would all start with some version of
this
you guys all have amazing visual
abilities in the back third of your
brain that does vision you can do all
this incredible stuff that no machine
can touch
hats off to you you have an amazing
visual system back here and those guys
in AI that is mostly guys guys gals
whatever those people in AI could only
dream of coming up with algorithms as
good as the one that's running in the
back of your head
you can't quite start the lectures that
way anymore so if any of you have been
living in a cave and not heard about
deep Nets there's been a massive
Revolution
and all of a sudden deep Nets are doing
things that are really close to human
abilities particularly in vision
so for example in visual object
recognition machines were way far behind
human Vision until very recently
especially when this paper here came out
was published in 2012
first author krishevsky
it has now been cited an astonishing 33
000 times actually I made this slide a
couple weeks ago it's probably been
cited 36 000 Times by now you can look
it up on Google Scholar and find out
that is a huge number of citations the
influence of this paper is ginormous
probably half of you have already heard
about this paper raise your hand if
you've heard about this paper oh okay
all right
right major big news okay
so what's so important about this paper
uh well they they trained as probably
most of you know they trained a deep net
on the over a million images in imagenet
a massive computer database of images
and they basically taught it to do
object recognition
and it performs much more accurately
than any previous system and it
approaches human abilities okay so this
is Major is a radical change in the
situation that we were in five years ago
so things have changed radically so just
as an example here's some of the um one
of the figures from that seminal paper
so here is one of the images from
imagenet that um that alexnet this
trained network was tested on and the
correct answer according to imagenet is
that that's a might and here's what
alexnet says it's number one first
answer is might in its second third
fourth answer is our Black Widow
cockroach Etc right so pretty damn good
the might is even sticking off the edge
of the frame and it gets it container
ship First Choice container ship pretty
good second choice makes sense Lifeboat
not bad
look at that motor scooter I can barely
even see the motor scooter in there but
alexnet awesome right leopard awesome
okay even when Alex net makes a mistake
the mistake is totally understandable
like according to imagenet that is a
picture of a grill and Alex net calls it
a convertible I'm siding with Alex net
on this one over image
this the correct answer is mushroom and
Alex net says agaric I had to look that
up it's like a particular kind of
mushroom
um this one's pretty funny
um imagenet says that's pictures of
cherry there's cherries in the
foreground but Alex net says Dalmatian
I'm siding with Alex net on this
um and you know Madagascar cat Etc so
pretty amazing and like nothing even
close to this was possible before 2012.
so this is very recent history and it
has totally shaken up the field in lots
of ways
um and so that's been transformative not
just for computer science but it's also
been transformative for cognitive
science and Neuroscience because now we
have algorithms like here's this deep
net and it does this thing so that's a
possible theory of how humans do it it's
a possible computationally precise
theory of what's going on in here and we
didn't used to have those and now we
have those for a number of domains and
that's shaking up the field there will
be a whole lecture on deep Nets and how
you can use them to think about minds
and brains toward the end of the course
guest lecture by my postdoc Katherine
Dobbs and we'll hear more about that
um but let's first step back a second
and say okay do they really perform as
well as humans even on just object
recognition
on images not in imagenet like imagenes
pretty good tests because these things
as you can see are highly variable they
have backgrounds they're complicated
they're real world images but you know
they were photographs taken by people in
a particular way what they you know with
a particular goal
um and most of the photographs you take
you throughout they don't end up in
imagenet right imagenet is a weird
little idiosyncratic subset of the kind
of visual experience that we have so
would this really generalize
so it so happens that um Boris Katz and
Andre barbu across the street in seasail
have been doing some very interesting
studies this stuff isn't published yet
but I got their permission to tell you
about this cool stuff they're doing and
they're saying hey let's test alexnet
and other similar deep Nets since then
uh on a more realistic harder version of
object recognition that's more
characteristic of what humans do and so
they're generating this huge data set of
stimuli that they crowdsource and so
people workers on Mechanical Turk go on
there and create images for them and so
they get instructions like you know hold
a hold a object in this particular
location or at this angle or move it
here and like send us the images so they
are getting I think hundreds of
thousands of images to test this on and
they're much more variable in the
location of the object in the image and
its orientation and so forth so for
example you guys have no problem telling
what that thing is but it's a slightly
atypical example likewise what's the
object on the floor there you can tell
what it is but it's it's slightly a
typical example
and so
um what Boris and Andre are finding
finding is that human performance is
still pretty good on these images
but the Deep Nets are terrible at this
stuff okay so resnet one of the more
recent ones drops from 71 correct on
imagenet to around 25 correct on these
images and the other
um similar fancy more recent networks do
similarly badly
so on the one hand uh AI the Deep Nets
are awesome and transformative no
question about it but on the other hand
despite all the hype they're still not
quite like human object recognition
right they're a whole lot closer than
they used to be but they're not really
there okay
and more generally what about harder
problems like image understanding not
just labeling and classification but
understanding what's going on in an
image okay so you guys have probably
seen image captioning Bots there are
lots of these around now this kind of
Hit the scene in 2016.
when Google AI came out with a
captioning algorithm and of course right
around the same time Microsoft had a
captioning algorithm and let's see how
they do so this is an example you give
this algorithm this picture here and it
says
um that's a dinosaur on top of a
surfboard
that's pretty damn good right like okay
wow
let's look more generally how well this
thing works at other examples okay it
looks at this and it says that's a group
of people on a field playing football
it's like wow okay
a snow-covered field
pretty good
view she win and uh ding ning posing for
a picture I don't know but these things
are very good at face recognition that's
probably exactly those two people right
a car parked in a parking or car yeah
car parked in a parking lot pretty good
a large ship in the water pretty good
a clock tower lit up at night awesome
right
a vintage photo of a pond
well the Vintage part I don't know where
the pond is there's a little water in
there I don't know not way off
a group of people that are standing in
the grass near a bridge
not really there's grass there's a
bridge sort of there's people but not
really right
a group of people standing on top of a
boat
definitely not
a building with a cake
what
a person holding a cell phone
not
a group of stuffed animals
I love this one a necklace made of
bananas
wow we've really landed on Mars here
sitting on the grass
talk about missing the boat
now look at this picture for a second
just figure out what's going on here
takes a couple seconds everyone got it
there's a lot going on here
okay
so this algorithm says I think it's a
group of people standing next to a man
in a suit and tie
and the algorithm is correct but the
algorithm has profoundly missed the boat
okay
so I'm channeling actually I stole these
slides from Josh Tenenbaum but let me
channel him for a moment and say what
his big idea is which I think is really
important
and that is that both humans and deep
Nets are very good at pattern
recognition pattern classification this
is a cat or a dog or a car or a toaster
right what they're not good at what
humans are good at but the Deep Nets are
not is building models to understand the
world
and so when you look at this picture
there are all kinds of things that are
crucial for really understanding at a
deep level what's going on in here we
need to know why some people what some
people here know but the guy on the
scale does not know
namely even if you don't recognize that
that James that that's James Comey I
think it is here's Obama with his foot
on the scale you need to know that
people find it embarrassing if they
weigh too much you need to know that he
can't see that Obama's doing it you need
to know that they can see it even though
he can't and that's kind of the essence
of humor there's just a whole universe
of Rich structural information going in
here that is part of what it means to
understand this picture
and no deep net is even close
to doing that kind of thing
okay
so bottom line of all this is or let me
just go on more generally
AI systems can't navigate new situations
infer what others believe use language
to communicate
write poetry and music to express how
they feel
or create math
to build Bridges devices and life-saving
medicines
that's a quote from our leader Jim
DiCarlo head of this department
published and wired a year ago in a
beautiful article on the limitations of
deep Nets
um but more generally the point is that
yes AI is taking a massive leap now when
we're right in the middle of it and it's
super exciting and it's helpful to
neuroscience and cognitive science
um but AI has a lot to learn from us too
right a lot to learn from what's going
on in here and how this thing works that
those AI systems still can't touch
okay so all of that was my third reason
for studying we're still in the Y are we
studying the human brain
the fourth reason to study the human
brain is the one most compelling to me
and that is that it is just simply the
greatest intellectual quest of all time
we could fight about cosmology I'm not
going to fight with you about anything
else I don't think there's any contest
it's the greatest intellectual quest of
all time and that's why I'm in it and
that's why I hope it'll be fun for you
okay that was the why
um how are we going to study the human
brain
so here's this thing how are we going to
figure out how it works it's kind of
daunting it's not totally obvious
the first thing to realize is that there
are lots of levels of organization in
this thing and hence lots of ways of
studying it we could look at molecules
and their interactions lots of people in
this building do that
we could look at properties of
individual neurons
we could look at circuits of neurons
interacting with each other
we look at entire brain regions and what
their functions are we could look at
networks of multiple brain regions
interacting with each other
and so all of those things are possible
but actually what we're going to do in
the course is none of those things in
particular instead we're going to ask a
somewhat different question and that
question is how does the brain give rise
to the mind
okay and to understand that question
we're going to do more at this level and
less at the upper levels okay
um so to answer this question we need to
start with the mind we need to if we're
going to understand how does this thing
produce a mind we need to First figure
out what is a mind what do we know about
minds
okay
um and so we need to start with the
various mental functions that Minds
carry out things like perception Vision
hearing
aspects of cognition like understanding
language thinking about people thinking
about things
Etc okay
and so for each mental function what
we're going to do in here
is start by trying to understand how it
works in Minds as well as we can or like
what it is that we're trying to
understand that Minds can do what is
computed and how
and then we're going to look at its
brain basis and try to figure out what
we can figure out about how that mental
function is implemented in a brain
so the first question we'll ask for all
of these domains is is there specialized
Machinery to do that thing
and then we'll ask what information is
represented in the relevant parts of the
brain and when is that information
represented
okay
and how
okay so how are we going to answer those
questions
well there's lots and lots of methods in
our field okay and so the first set of
methods if we want to understand mines
the first set of methods are the basic
stuff of cognitive science psychophysics
that means showing people visual stimuli
or playing them sounds and asking them
what they see or hear nice and low Tech
but lots has been learned from those
methods you collect reaction time and
accuracy and it's amazing how much you
can learn from these methods that have
been around for
100 years or more
perceptual Illusions are similarly very
informative about how minds work
now let me say an important thing that
arises here
last year was the first time I taught
this course and I would say it went
so-so I'm aiming for it to be much
better this year and one of the ways I'm
trying to do that is to be responsive to
the student of owls I got last year
which were not fabulous across the board
hurt my feelings badly but once I got
over myself I decided to just listen to
them and try to fix it and one way to
fix it is to be honest with you today
about what this course is going to cover
so in my avails student 50458 bless them
offer this comment
this class was not sold in the correct
way it should not be called the human
brain because it was basically just a
cognitive science not a brain class I
expected to learn very different
material
so I don't know who the student is I
wish I could apologize to them but I
will say to you uh sorry student 50458
sorry I didn't make that clear
the fundamental reason the brain is cool
is that it gives rise to the mind
and that means that studying you know
the biological properties of the brain
without considering the mental functions
it implements
it would be kind of like trying to study
the physical properties of a book
without considering the meaning of its
text
so we're going to spend a lot of time
doing cognitive science in here and if
you had a different impression uh sorry
about that but that's what we're doing
here
okay
all right so how are we going to answer
it so lots of cognitive science
um so how are we going to look at the
brain basis well we're going to look at
neuropsychology patients people like Bob
who have damage to the brain and what
functions get preserved and lost we'll
use we'll look at a lot of studies with
functional MRI neurophysiology where you
can record from Individual neurons in
animal brains and in rare occasion cases
even in human brains under clinical
situations where they need to have
electrodes in their brain anyway for
neurosurgery we'll look at EEG recorded
from electrodes on the scalp
um and Meg recording from magnetic
fields from squids placed next to the
scalp we'll look at connectivity
measures with a method called diffusion
tractography
Etc so lots of methods and so which
mental functions will we cover
well to tell you about that I need to
tell you about the huge progress that
has happened in our field in the last 20
years okay all of this is quite recent
and so let's back up to 1990 here is
approximately what we knew about the
organization of the human brain in 1990.
the black ovals are the bits that are
primary sensory and motor regions that
have been known for a long time even by
1990.
and the colored bits are the bits where
we had some idea that face recognition
might go on somewhere in the back end of
the bottom of the right hemisphere
because of people who had damage back
there and lost their face recognition
ability
sometimes preserving their ability to
visually recognize words and faces words
and scenes and objects only losing their
ability to recognize faces okay
the language regions we had known about
for nearly 200 years from broca and
Wernicke and others who had studied
patients with damage in those regions
and noted that they had problems with
language function
and similarly many people had reported
that if you have damage up here in the
parietal lobes you sometimes lose your
ability to direct your attention to
different places in the visual scene so
that was approximately what was known in
1990
and here's what we know now
we now know thanks largely to functional
MRI
um that for dozens of regions in the
brain in every one of you we have a
pretty good idea of the function of that
region
this is Major progress right this is a
kind of rough sketch of the organization
of the human mind and brain that we have
now that we didn't have 20 years ago
and that's awesome
um and so that is made possible a lot of
progress building with other methods and
so what we'll study in this course
is we'll focus on those mental functions
where the brain bases are best
understood okay and that will include
things like the visual perception of
color shape and motion
visual recognition of faces places
bodies and words
and scenes didn't make it on the slide
oh yes it did perceiving scenes and
navigating
understanding numbers
yes there's a whole lot about the brain
basis of understanding numbers
perceiving speech and perceiving music
understanding language
understanding other people and their
minds okay so those are the kinds of
topics where there's been a lot of
progress recently in understanding the
brain basis of those mental functions
and so those are the ones we'll focus on
and that means there's going to be a lot
on perception high level vision and high
level audition
um because you know that's one where a
lot of progress has been made and it's
also a lot of the cortex right as I
mentioned a moment ago the whole back
third of your brain does vision
construed broadly
right and so some people might say why
are she spending all this time in Vision
well it's like a big part of what your
brain does we are very visual animals so
we'll spend a lot of time on vision
um okay and so for each of these
functions we will ask
to what extent is this mental function
implemented in its own specialized brain
machinery
are there multiple different brain
regions that carry out that function
what does each one do is there a
division of labor between those
different regions
how does that system arise in
development
how does it does it have homologs in
other species are these things uniquely
human or which of them are
and also along the way other side cool
questions that will come up
what if anything is special about the
human brain
how come we are taking over and largely
destroying the planet and other species
are not right besides destroying the
planet we're doing some other cool
things like inventing science and
engineering and medicine and
architecture and poetry and literature
and all these other and music all these
other awesome things that other species
aren't doing how come our brains are
doing that and other species aren't
where does knowledge come from
you guys know all this stuff
how much of that stuff was wired in at
Birth and how much of it did you get
from experience
um how much can our minds and brains
change over time can we go study a new
thing and get a whole new brain region
for that thing
um
can we change the basic structure just
by training
or after brain damage
can we think without language
right how many of you have wondered
about that question
yeah really basic question
Anya's answering it Anya and some others
but Anya's doing a lot to answer that
question they're actually empirical
answers to these long-standing deep
questions that everyone wonders about
that's pretty cool
um
somebody back there asked a while ago
about awareness can we think perceive
understand without awareness how much
can go on like in the basement of the
brain when we don't even know what's
going on down there we'll consider all
of these other cool questions
okay there's a bunch of things we won't
cover in this course
um for various reasons that could have
been in here and just aren't there's
only so much time motor control it's
really important to know how you do
things like pick up objects and plan
actions and um
we're just not covering that something
had to go
um subcortical function all this is a
very corticocentric course most of the
course will deal with the cortex that's
where most of conscious thinking and
reasoning and cognition happens there's
a lot of good stuff down in the basement
of the brain and it's going to get
pretty short shrift okay not for any
good reason
what it is decision making important
field not getting much coverage in here
importantly circuit level mechanisms
explanations of cognition like if you
think that we're going to understand not
only what it means to understand the
meaning of a sentence but that I'm going
to give you a wiring diagram of the
neurons that Implement that function
sorry to be the bearer of bad news but
nobody has a freaking clue how you could
get a bunch of neurons to understand the
meaning of a sentence okay so that's
exciting that means there's a field for
you guys to waltz into and probably in
your lifetimes people will start to
crack these things right but you know
just to know what we're headed into
rarely for almost no high level mental
functions do we have anything like a
wiring diagram level understanding of
any perceptual or cognitive function
okay
so that's not in the cards for this
course because it doesn't exist in the
field
um okay for that kind of thing there are
cases where you can make progress you
can understand say fear conditioning in
a mouse like those circuits are being
like cracked wide open by people in this
building people all around the world
with spectacular Precision they know the
specific classes of neurons their
connectivity they know every damn thing
about them but it's like you know how
does a mouse learn that this thing is to
be afraid of this thing okay that's
important
you know
for more complex aspects of cognition in
humans we can't usually have that kind
of circuit level understanding
lots of other things that will get short
shrift memory not for any good reason I
mean there's a lot of coverage of memory
in 900 and 901
and it's just somehow off a blind spot
for understanding I've heard knowing how
to talk interestingly about memory so
I'm not going to give you a boring
lecture on memory instead I'm not going
to give you any lecture on memory until
I learn how to talk about it
interestingly
reinforcement learning and reward
systems I'm going to try to pull some of
that in but it's not going to be a major
Focus even though it's a really
important part of cognition attention
there might be some at the end okay
um okay how many of you have taken 900.
okay looks like a little over a half
okay how many have taken 901.
yeah a little over half okay good so
um uh if you okay so if you have great
good for you this course is designed for
as a tier two course for people who have
taken 900 or 901 if you haven't you're
probably okay but you might need to do a
little extra work and so I've already
posted online
uh and in the syllabus information about
actually a lecture I gave a year ago on
some of the background stuff that is no
longer taught in this course people
hated it when I taught them stuff they'd
already encountered before so I'm trying
to minimize that uh and so that's a
backup for those of you who haven't
taken these courses if you're worried
about this chat with me afterwards I
think it will be okay just count on
doing a little bit of extra work not
much
um okay for those of us you have who
have taken it
um there's going to be a little bit of
overlap it's simply impossible to have
zero overlap I mean what does John
gabrielli and 900 and Mark bear and 901
do they survey the whole broad field and
they pick the coolest stuff out of every
little bit and they teach it to you
exactly as they should but that means
that when I come along and try to say
I'm going to do a more intensive
coverage of the coolest things there's
going to be a teeny bit of overlap but
I'll try to not make it too much okay
just because the coolest stuff is the
coolest stuff right
uh okay
um yeah
also the spin and the goals of this
course are quite different from both 900
and 901
you will have to memorize a few things
but not much my real goal in this course
is to have you understand things not
memorize a sea of disjointed facts okay
so a little more on the goals
really what I want you to get out of
this course is to appreciate the big
questions in the field and what is at
stake theoretically in each okay
um I want you to understand the methods
in human cognitive Neuroscience what
each one can tell you what it can't how
different combinations of methods can
work synergistically and complementally
to answer different facets of a question
um
I do want you to gain some actual
knowledge about some of the domains of
cognition where we've learned a bunch
both at the cognitive level and the
Brain level
things like face recognition navigation
language understanding music stuff like
that
and crucially I want you guys to be able
to read current papers in the field so
if you look in the syllabus the first
few papers are like 20 years old but
it's going to accelerate quickly and
you'll be reading papers I'm trying to
choose mostly papers published in the
last year or two okay I'm trying to take
you straight to The Cutting Edge of the
field okay yeah part of the people is
that people straight out of research
Labs or are they going to be like their
annual meeting nope straight out of
research Labs you're going to read the
real deal not someone else's uh blurry
just they just read the abstracts and
put in some stuff in the review article
no you're going to read the actual paper
that's the whole deal yep
um okay so those are the goals
good
a few things why no textbook this field
is moving too fast for a textbook plus I
have strong opinions and I don't like
any of the textbooks
um so any textbook is out of date we're
going to be reading hot stuff that's hot
off the press and so there's no that's
not in the textbooks yet and so we're
skipping that and you're going to go
straight to original research article so
we'll be occasional review articles
where relevant but mostly part of the
agenda of this course is to teach you to
be not afraid of and able to read
current articles in the field
all right you've all been waiting for
this okay details on the grading pretty
standard midterm 25 of the class of the
grade final 25 it will be cumulative but
weighted toward the second half
um there's going to be a lot of reading
and writing assignments
approximately uh two papers to read per
week
um and for usually one of those papers
per week you will have a very short uh
written assignment in which usually I
ask a few simple questions and maybe one
like paragraph level think question
um the essence of these tasks is not the
written resignment itself the essence of
the task is to understand the paper if
you've understood the paper as you read
it then you should be able to answer
those questions pretty straightforwardly
um and let me just say that
understanding a scientific paper is not
trivial when I read a scientific paper
right in my area where I have all of the
background it takes me hours hours
it may be five pages it still takes me
hours
it's just how it is so when I assign a
paper and you say this oh it's only
three pages you know I can I could do
that in 20 minutes oh no you can't no
you can't right and that's part of what
I want you learn to learn how to do is
how to like really read and understand a
scientific paper allocate the time it
takes to really get it okay so that's a
big part of the agenda in this task
okay all the stuff
um the assignments and the submission of
the assignments will all happen on
Stellar your first written response to a
paper is due February 12th at 6 pm on
Stellar but there are other readings
that are assigned before that a note
about the schedule I struggled a lot
trying to both have the assignments
happen when you had already learned
enough in lectures to know how to do it
but have it close enough to the topic at
hand so it didn't seem like no longer
relevant that's hard to do both of those
things so the compromise is all of the
assignments are due at 6 PM the night
before the class in which they're
assigned and so if you see that it's
assigned you know on the 13th if it's
listed on the lecture for the 13th check
carefully it's probably due the night of
the I'm getting this wrong the 12th the
night before and that's so that we and
the Tas can look at it figure out what
you understood what you didn't and how
to incorporate and explain whatever you
didn't get in the next lecture okay
all right
um quizzes I haven't done this before
new thing I'm going to try uh they're
going to be about eight of these they're
going to be very brief they're going to
happen at the end of class in class and
you will do them on your computer or
your iPhone using Google forms if
anybody doesn't have a computer or an
iPhone they can bring to class the days
of those quizzes let us know after class
and we'll come up with a solution okay
and the idea of these is not to fish out
an obscure fact that was in one of the
reading assignments and you know ding
you on it like I'm not interested in
that the the goal of this is just to
keep you up to date keep you doing the
readings keep you up with the material
and if you basically are understanding
what you're reading and understanding
the lecture material maybe you glance at
it briefly before you should do fine on
the quizzes they're just kind of reality
checks right for us to know what people
are getting and not okay
uh okay first quiz is February 20th uh
blah blah there is one longer written
assignment that is not due with the
usual schedule of all the other things
it's due near the end and in that one
you will actually design an experiment
in a particular area and that will be I
don't know yet three to five pages
something like that we'll give you more
details on exactly how you want to
organize this and it will be very
specific like State your exact
hypothesis State your exact experimental
design Etc and you'll get practice with
those things in advance
all right so those are the grading and
requirements
um and this is the um you have this all
in the syllabus in front of you this is
the lineup of topics but very briefly
let me try to give you the Arc of the
class
um so this is the introduction next time
we're going to do just a teeny bit of
neuroanatomy there will be a teeny bit
of overlap with 900 and 901 there I'm
going to whip through it in very
superficial form I'm doing that largely
because on the following class we have
an amazing privilege which is at one of
the greatest neuroscientists alive today
and Graybill will be doing an actual
brain dissection right here in this
class right in front of you it's going
to be awesome I can't wait it's an
incredible privilege it will be a real
human brain and you guys will be and
will be here with all her apparatus and
you guys will be clustered around and if
it's this many God help us but we'll
figure out how to make it work I may let
me just say if there are listeners in
here I may have to tell listeners they
can't come because very sensitive about
not having too many people so stay tuned
on that I haven't quite decided yet
depends how many people are taking
um but it's going to be amazing
and I want to remind you of just some
Basics so you're not asking her like
what is the hippocampus okay so I know
you I know you should all know that but
we'll just do bear basics
um okay and then we'll have the
dissection that will be great and also
another thing to say is I mentioned that
the subcortical regions are going to get
short shrift in this class that's true
um but a lot of what you see in a
dissection is a subcortical stuff right
cortex is great but it kind of all looks
the same you kind of can't say oh that's
the this region that's the other
Regional you can but it doesn't look any
different from any other region
so um so that's where the subcortical
stuff will happen okay
okay uh so then I'm going to do a couple
of lectures that focus on High level
vision
perceiving motion and color and shape
and faces and scenes and bodies and
stuff like that and we will use those
both to teach you that content and also
to teach you the you know vast array of
methods in this field okay
we will then have a lecture on the kind
of debates about the organization of
visual cortex in humans I have a
particular view I'm I'm very fond of
views that some patches of Cortex are
very very functionally specific not
everyone believes that so I have
assigned readings of people who have
different views we will consider that I
will try to expose you to the alternate
views and tell you why I'm teaching why
I still believe mine but why other smart
people believe different things right
okay we will then move up the system
from perception and we will spend two
meetings talking about scene perception
and navigation you've got a hint about
what an interesting area this is from
the story of Bob we'll consider more
what we've learned from studies of
patients with brain damage from
functional MRI from physiology and
animals from cognitive science from the
whole glorious menagerie of methods to
understand navigation it's a it's a
really fascinating area
the in the two lectures after that we'll
consider development how do you wire up
a brain how much is present at birth
what is specified in the genes what is
learned and a lot of that will focus on
the navigation system and the face
system simply because that's where
there's a lot known right we'll consider
some other things but those are two
areas where there's
super exciting work from just the last
three or four years and so that's what
we'll focus on there
I'm then going to do a lecture on brains
in blind people how are they different
how are they the same what does that
tell us
and then you have the midterm
then we're going to move on and consider
number how do you like instantly know
that that's three fingers and that's two
without having to do anything all that
complicated and if I had 25 fingers and
held them up you would immediately get a
sense that it was about 25 you might not
know if it was 22 or 28 but you would
know it was about 25 and there are
particular brain regions that compute
that for you and we will consider all of
that and there's a very rich array of
information from studies of infant
cognition from animal behavior from
brain Imaging from brain damage from
single unit physiology and from
computation all of which inform our
understanding of number those are my
favorite lectures so we can take one
domain of cognition and inform it with
like all of the methods and numbers are
really great example
uh then we'll talk a little bit about uh
well one of my Tas said call it neuro
economics it will sound good but
actually what I'm going to try to do is
sort of neuroeconomics but it will be
about
um
uh
uh Pleasure and Pain and reward and how
we think about those things
okay
um and then that's down to April 3rd
just as a side note all of these things
are things that are pretty similar
between humans and at least primates and
some of them are shared with rodents
okay
and most of the things after that are
things that are really uniquely human
okay so we'll be really moving away with
less available animal literature to
inform the stuff we're looking at
because animals can't do these things
and so necessarily far from the details
of individual neurons in circuits but
there's still Lots cool that can be said
about how you understand speech how you
appreciate music
there will be a guest lecture just for
fun on brain machine interface by
Michael Cohen who's working in my lab
now and who has a great lecture on this
topic
and then we'll spend a couple lectures
on language how you understand and
produce language and what the relevant
brain regions are what we know about it
from cognition and lots of other methods
and what the relationship is between
language and thought
then we'll think about how we think
about other people this is called theory
of Mind how I can look out at this
lecture and try to evaluate from your
facial expression are they bored sleepy
overworked fascinated excited all of
this kind of stuff that all of us do
moment to moment in any conversation and
that you know yes lectures are doing all
the time
even if I know that you guys have too
much work and that's why you're sleepy
and I shouldn't take it personally
um I'm still noticing anyway
then we'll go on and consider brain
networks right so of course brain
function doesn't happen in just a single
region even if we spend a lot of time
studying individual regions there's
considerable work trying to figure out
which sets of regions work together and
how could we discover that and what are
those broader networks of brain regions
and then on May 6 you will have turned
in your longer written assignment
designing your own experiment and then
it makes on May 6 we will work together
in groups to refine those experiments
and really hash out the details so you
actually know how to design an
experiment
um and then we will have this guest
lecture
from my postdoc katharina Dobbs on deep
Nets and what they can tell us about
cognition and brains
and then we'll talk about attention
awareness
and then I'm not totally sure what we're
gonna do in the last class but what I'm
voting for is that the amazing Tas each
give a short talk on the cool stuff
they're doing but that's under
discussion
okay that's the Arc of the class
um questions
all clear
great well if I have five more minutes
maybe I'll do one other little thing
let me try this
um you asked I'm gonna try to learn
everybody's names but I'm not doing that
yet because some of you might not show
up and I will have wasted a whole piece
of my brain encoding it out just kidding
um uh but um anyway I remember that you
asked like you know gonna read current
papers yes it is and you're right it's a
it's daunting but let me just say a
little bit about how to read papers this
is not a stats course and we haven't
prerequisite prerequisited stats neither
is is it a course on the physics of MRI
so there will be parts of every MRI
paper that have a lot of gobbledygook we
scanned with this scanning procedure
right you know we use this kind of
scanner and this kind of blah blah blah
lots of gobbledygook you guys don't need
to worry about that about the stats it's
kind of a judgment call everyone in here
should have an idea of what a p level
means and I hope a sense of what a
t-test is and an anova if you don't I
should probably tell you that offline
because that's you know pretty basic but
be and what a correlation is beyond that
just use your intuitions about those
things and we and this is not a course
about understanding the details of the
stats in each experiment there just
isn't room to cover all that in the
substance of the studies as well
so when you read a paper for example
here's a paper
a very old paper you come across this
and it's like okay here are all these
words like I know it goes on for 20
pages and like how do you even dig in
well way to dig in
is to start by saying what question is
being asked in this paper
if the paper is Well written you'll be
able to find that in the abstract blah
blah blah to study the effect of face
inversion on the human fusiform face
area okay we'll talk about that more
later but if you fish through the
abstract you should be able to find what
questions being asked and it's the first
thing you should figure out about a
paper
okay
you don't necessarily read a paper you
know start to be beginning through the
end I think it's better to start with
this list of questions in your head and
look for the answers to those questions
right
second question what do they find
if the abstract is Well written you can
find that in the abstract as well
signal intensity from the fusiform face
area was reduced when grayscale faces
were presented upside down
okay kind of boring but there it is
that's a finding this paper
okay
what is the interpretation like in other
words who cares like why who you know
who cares about this okay
um
if you look in here in the abstract FFA
responds to faces per se rather than to
the low level features present in faces
okay we'll talk more about what that
means you guys have an assignment about
that probably several assignments about
that kind of question okay
um
next question you want to ask yourself
is what is the design of this experiment
often for this you have to go beyond the
abstract and I should say for even these
ques these earlier questions sometimes
you won't find them in the abstract that
just means the abstract is not well
written
but that exists okay to get the design
like what exactly did they do usually
you have to fit and you know what
exactly was done and how were the data
analyzed you need to fish farther you
need to fish around
um other parts of the paper
and of course all of those questions
okay so I just said okay what question
and we just I circled this part but
there are many levels to what question
so you can get more on you know why why
is that inverted question important you
look through usually in the introduction
to the paper
does the FFA respond to faces per se or
to a confounding visual feature which
tends to be present in faces second is
it true that inverted vases cannot
engage face specific mechanisms blah
blah blah so that gives you a little
more background on what the question is
right there are different levels of
depth okay so these are all things you
want to be looking for when you read a
paper
what exactly was done we measured MRI
responses in the FFA to Upright inverted
phases right I don't expect you to
understand all this is you're just
giving you schematically how you proceed
when you're reading a paper okay
um more on the interpretation or who
cares right this result would show that
face-specific mechanisms are engaged
only or predominantly by upright faces
blah blah blah right you can fish
through for those things point is to
have those questions in your head when
you read a paper okay
it's much it's much more easy and
engaging to read something if you have
an agenda when you read it and so your
agenda in Reading scientific papers is
to answer those questions for yourself
right
uh uh more stuff what was the design and
logic often that's deep in the methods
you have to fish around and find it
there will be some set of conditions and
Designs we'll talk more about all this
kind of stuff
what exactly was done you know blah blah
more details
okay and this is my example of the kind
of gobbledygook that you can ignore okay
so subjects were scanned on a one and a
half T scanner and they're all these
like this here's the example of God said
gobbledygook you can ignore this in this
class right every method will have
different kinds of gobbledygook this is
MRI gobbledygook you can ignore it okay
uh I'm it matters a lot but not here
okay
uh what else how are the data analyzed
if you look in the um you know sometimes
there's a data analysis section or a
result section or a method section that
will tell you you can find that figure
it out okay
um what was the finding here's more on
the finding again you just fish through
for these things so the point is just
when you're reading a paper you don't
it's not necessarily I think what I do
is I read the title I read the abstract
and then I start answering those
questions for myself and sometimes at
that point I'm skipping to figures I'm
skipping to methods any of that is fine
okay
so don't feel like you need to
understand each word especially deep in
the methods I don't know was that
helpful at all
we'll try it and you guys will give me
feedback and if it works great and if
not we'll we'll do more on how to read
papers
all right
it's 12 25. see you on Monday